If you were here in August
and you were sitting on the beach,
on a blanket facing the sea,
you would think you were
in the Turks and Caicos
in the Caribbean.
The beaches have been renamed
Spiagge Bianche in Italian,
which literally means "the white beaches"
and you'll see hundreds of beachgoers
flocking to that
destination in the summers.
Vogue Italia magazine
put the white beaches on its cover.
I mean, it's strikingly beautiful
but this sort of Caribbean-like oasis
also has a dirty secret.
Well, here's this enormous chemical plant
on the beaches of Tuscany.
And for over 100 years,
it has been pumping 24/7, 365 days a year
its discharge straight onto the coast
and into the coastal waters.
It's visible on the beach,
it's visible from space even.
So much so that it has literally
transformed the landscape.
The beaches are now
a stark and bright white,
whereas all around that area
the beaches are sort
of a more beigy color.
And the question that came up is
how could that possibly be legal,
that a chemical plant
can just take left over
and just pump it out into the sea?
And so we set out to answer that question,
you know, is it okay?
Is it damaging the environment
and hurting people?
And the answer was
actually more complicated
than we thought it would be.
Solvay is a multinational
chemicals company
based in Brussels, Belgium.
It's got a market value
of far over 10 billion euros.
Its operations are all around the world.
Well, here's a town, Rosignano Solvay,
which has the name suggests,
takes its name from the
company for a reason.
Over 100 years ago
when Solvay spotted this location
on the coast of Italy,
as infrastructure was
being built around it,
it found a location
which would be suitable
for its production
and literally built a
town around the plant.
I mean we're talking schools,
we're talking a hospital, a theater.
So this town is literally
the embodiment of the company
and its plant in Tuscany.
This is a plant that makes soda ash,
an ingredient in glass
and it's used for other things.
And essentially they take
local limestone from quarries
and bring it in and pulverize it.
What essentially,
what is being discharged are tiny,
tiny particles of limestone
mixed in seawater.
And that is what is making
the beach in part that color.
Their position is they take
locally quarried, natural stone
and they put it through their plant.
And that the totally
natural sandy byproduct
is just pushed out to the sea
where it does a terrific job contributing
to the environment by helping the beach
not fall victim to erosion.
But the process itself of pulverizing
the stone unlocks natural metals,
minerals that are inside the stone.
Arsenic, mercury, zinc, lead.
Some of it is dissolved in the water
and some of it is still in particles,
in compounds that are part of the rock.
And every year they pump the equivalent
of almost 250,000 tons
of these suspended solids
directly onto the beach
and into the Mediterranean.
The Italian government,
as they just have,
reauthorized them with a new license,
they get their stamp of approval.
And it seems there that life goes on.
Except that we've been able
to answer part of the question about,
is it legal, should it be legal?
Well under Italian law,
the one legal standard the company
has to meet reflects the concentration
of heavy metals in the discharge.
What that means is
it cannot exceed certain thresholds
of milligrams per liter of heavy metals
in its discharge.
And it turns out that in 2013,
it had exceeded those
concentration limits.
And it never went to trial.
It went to a plea bargain for polluting
the beach around the plant
and of diluting the effluent
in a way that disguised the fact
that they were exceeding legal limits
such as mercury that were going
directly into the Mediterranean.
And this was a turning point.
Solvay promised to the court that
it would somehow treat
for those heavy metals
to reduce the concentrations.
The result was that Solvay
has not changed how it produces soda ash,
nor how it discharges the pollutants.
It has simply relabeled
some of the plant's processes.
They're taking sea water,
which doesn't count to
their fraction normally
because it's just used to cool
all the hot stuff in the plants.
It's not part of the production itself.
It's cooling water comes in from the sea,
goes out, doesn't count
towards their concentration.
They built something in
treating for ammonia,
that routed about a third of this seawater
through a new apparatus that they built,
that let them raise
the denominator of their fraction.
So without changing the amount
of heavy metals coming out,
the bottom half of that
got higher and higher
as they put online this new system.
And now it's almost impossible
to tell if they have any heavy metals
going out the door.
The company is very straightforward.
We asked them,
"Have you reduced the
amount of heavy metals?"
And they said,
"No, nothing that we've done
"reduces the concentrations,
"increases the concentrations, unchanged."
But what they have done
is accounted for water differently.
In an email exchange with us,
the company asserted
that the Italian court
never determined that the
crimes were committed.
A really key turning point
was getting the paperwork from the court,
which we were able to
make a special request
by citing public interest
in our status as journalists,
to get the actual documentation
of what happened in court that day.
And it says by how much,
mercury limit was exceeded
by six times over, 50% over, 30% over.
That having these raw numbers
and then going back
and seeing it's never been
in any of their filings to shareholders.
They've never described it that way.
They don't really ever talk about it
and seemed like it kind
of an important moment
and so, we knew that we were seeing
a difference between
what was being presented to the public,
being presented to investors
and the hard documentation,
and that hard documentation
had never come out before.
The idea that this
is going on 365 days a year
with no attempt to hide it.
There's no wall behind
which you need to peer.
There's no boundaries around this trench
that literally goes into the sea.
And in the summers,
I've seen it with my own eyes,
there are people literally bathing
right on the ditch,
right where the discharge enters the sea.
The water is a little bit warmer,
perhaps that's what attracts
some of the bathers.
And the community that
lives around this plant
has elevated levels of diseases.
Showing causality, always difficult.
But there is a lot that the activists
have gotten their teeth into
about showing that there is an impact.
Activists have described the attitude
here as resignation.
Some people don't want to know what's,
you know, in the air and in the soil.
We spoke to some of the residents,
most of whom were rather
indifferent to the plant,
even the lady who lives right
on the footsteps of the plant
sort of shrugged her shoulders
and said, "You know, you've
gotta die of something."
And when we made our way
to the plant's entrance,
well, the reception
there was quite frosty.
We came here and security
at the front gate of the plant
stopped Elisa because
she was taking pictures
and they threatened to call the police.
And so she joked this morning that,
you know, be careful
when the police stop you
so they don't break your cameras.
Sure enough, when we were
filming our interview
with an activist on the beach,
men in plain clothes came up behind us
when we were done,
flashed their badges
and wanted to see ID,
and wanted to know who
we were working for.
You don't get close to this plant
without somebody knowing who you are,
what you're doing and making you feel
a little uncomfortable about being here.
I think the trouble
with the regulation is,
as we found,
is in part the disjointed nature.
On the one hand, you have the courts,
they enforce the law, they prosecute.
On the other hand,
you have the environment ministry,
which is now in charge of regulating
and allowing Solvay to operate a plant.
It wasn't clear to us
just how much communication
there was between for example,
the courts and the environment ministry.
We know that prosecutors
are looking at Solvay again,
though it's not clear what the basis
of their investigation might be,
how advanced and who it
might be focusing on.
So you've launched
a pretty high profile campaign
to get the CEO of Solvay removed.
Another important turning point
was the entry onto the scene of Bluebell,
an activist investor group
based in London.
And you know,
every year they pick another target
and buy one share.
In this case,
they bought one share of Solvay
and they went after the company for its,
for its Italian plant.
And what this did was create
a ton of publicity around this
and raised some really good questions.
And what caught our eye
was at the 2021 shareholders meeting.
They asked a lot of questions
about the water flowing in,
the water flowing out.
And they didn't get a lot of answers.
They got a lot of apples and oranges
figures from the company.
Companies certainly didn't tell them
what they could have,
which was that they had changed
how they account for the water
starting in 2019.
What happens next is Solvay
is facing a litany of challenges.
They're facing it with
a potential prosecution
in the Livorno courts.
They're facing it with an uprising
from this activist investor.
They're facing it from activists
who are energized by the fact
that some had no idea
that the government here in Italy
was about to renew their license
for another 12 years.
And that renewal there
is really important to them
and staying in business here,
and being viable and not having found
to have violated any laws
or have problems with disclosure.
They need everything to go right for them.
Not just because this is,
you know, 17% of their global business
and one that they wanna
sell or dispose of,
but because it could affect their stock.
I mean, always you can see it,
the fact that they're pushing back
against this activist investor
and trying to discredit him
with public statements.
This is a turning point for this company.
As things stand there are no indications
that Solvay intends to change this process
in this particular location.
And the change will probably
have to come from above.
The change will probably have
to come from policy that is updated
to reflect the norms and practices
that are used elsewhere.
But it is astounding that no matter
what is being discharged,
the sheer volume of it,
and the fact that it's affecting
the landscape is carrying on
and has been carrying on for decades.